I want to go through our overall plan
for beating this new coronavirus first
we must stop the disease spreading to a
point weight overwhelms our NHS and
every country in the world has the same
problem this is a disease that is so
dangerous and so infectious that without
drastic measures to check its progress
it would overwhelm any health system in
the world and I've used the Italian
Health System it is excellent and the
problem is not with the health systems
it's the numbers of sufferance that's
why we announced the steps yesterday
that we did advising against all
unnecessary contact steps that are
unprecedented since world war ii i
stress that although the measures an
hour already extreme we may well have to
go further and faster in the coming days
to protect lives and the NHS the
government will stand behind businesses
small and large i can announce today an
unprecedented package of government
backed and guaranteed loans to support
business to get through this today I am
making available an initial 330 billion
pounds of guarantees equivalent to 15%
of our GDP that means any business who
needs access to cash to pay their rent
their salaries suppliers or purchase
stock will be able to access a
government backed loan or credit on
attractive terms and if demand is
greater than the initial three hundred
and thirty billion pounds I'm making
available today I will go further and
provide as much capacity as required I
said whatever it takes and I meant it
that support will be delivered through
two main schemes to support liquidity
amongst larger firms I have today agreed
a new lending facility with the governor
of the Bank of England to provide
low-cost easily accessible commercial
paper to support lending to small and
medium sized businesses I'm extending
the
new business interruption loan scheme I
announced a budget last week so that
rather than loans of 1.2 million pounds
it will now provide loans of up to five
million pounds with no interest you for
the first six months both of these
schemes will be up and running by the
start of next week and I am also taking
a new legal power in the kovat ville to
offer whatever further financial support
I decide is necessary